the joggin experience it's your take on
sweet and Sweden's the way they're
handling this which is essentially
they're giving people the freedom to go
to restaurants and bars and they're
shutting some things down but they're
quite a bit more open than the rest of
the world and subsequently they're
they're experiencing a spike in cases
yeah I mean the problem again is without
a vaccine or other technologies we have
to use go back to the 14th century
that's when quarantine was invented it
was when ships would come into the
harbor on Croatia and coming from Asia
Minor and they were fearful they're
bringing plague and they kept the ships
for 40 days that's the word where the
word quarantine came from and that's
well we've got right now so we know
social distancing is probably our only
hope and and there's a few pieces of
evidence for that I mean it's real
serious social distancing not going to
restaurants and things so my colleague
mark lipstick is a brilliant
epidemiologist at Harvard has been you
know doing a lot of analyses and
modeling and one of the things he's
shown is that when he looks at the
cities in China for instance where they
did social distancing and other
aggressive measures and something that
were pretty aggressively couldn't even
do in the United States but the showed
that the longer you allow transmission
to go on before you intervene with
social distancing and other things the
worse the surge and the worst the
epidemic and therefore us we talked
about in Italy the worse the mortality
so for instance in Wuhan where he
estimates I think I forget the exact
numbers I think he's found about 6 weeks
of transmission going out before you
intervene then it was lights out it was
a massive surge in hospital systems
getting overwhelmed and a lot of health
care workers getting sick and and I want
to come back to that point and after we
finished those as opposed to in southern
China and other places in China where
you intervened after a week then you got
you know there was the difference
between having two thousand patients in
your ICU across the city versus 20 that
that's how the dramatic a difference so
that's a lesson we need to learn for the
u.s. is
it's the only thing we have and to
really push hard on the social
distancing and I think it's especially
important in the cities because it looks
to me like what we're seeing so far in
the u.s. is more of an urban / suburban
versus rural divide we're seeing the big
surges and I see patients more in cities
in rural areas although dr. Fadi
Africans last night the other night said
don't ignore the rural areas either
because we don't know what's going to
happen there so social distancing is
absolutely paramount and unfortunately
what's happening because things got so
[ __ ] up with the testing that we've
not we've some unfortunate we've often
found out that transmission is going out
for several weeks only when a lot of ICU
patients started hitting the door so
this is what happened in New Orleans is
what happened is probably happening in
Detroit the mayor of Atlanta just said
you know all of a sudden we found all of
these people show up in the eye and the
ICU so that's a another lesson learned
we really not only doing the the
diagnostic testing but the social
distancing is really important and I've
been on calls with the leadership of
people in Houston because you know
you're right it's it's it it's hurting
the economy in so many ways but you know
if you want to prevent Houston from
replicating the New Orleans experience
I've been saying to the to the mayor and
everyone else in Houston this is
unfortunately what we're going to have
to do and the models are showing that
that's the Oregon Institute in
Washington Seattle Washington called the
Institute for Health metrics and
evaluation and it's they've now been
looking at this they do all these
amazing things to look at the not only
epidemic diseases but also chronic
non-communicable diseases diabetes heart
disease and mental health issues but
they've been you know all hands on deck
at this kovat epidemic and they've just
put it out on their website it's health
data or Gandy go to the co vid 19 site
and what they're showing is that they
anticipate the peak of this epidemic in
the US
is going to hit about the middle of
April so we're not even at the peak yet
and so we're two weeks of this is going
to continue to go up and in some places
like in Texas is going to be delayed
it's probably going to be around around
many second and I think California was
around there as well so their numbers
say it's going to be the next two months
that are going to be the crunch time
when it's going to start really going up
and then as we move into later in May
it'll start to go down and maybe really
bottom out by June of course again it's
a model it's a new virus pathogen but
what I've been saying is you know the
president yesterday or the day before
said ok I understand I said Easter now
we're going to go to April 30th and my
point is well April 30th things are
still going to be peaking in parts of
the country let's use April 30 as a time
to reassess and then make a decision
whether we go another months let's go a
month at a time for now until we know
where this is heading
[Applause]